these are the emojis that Gen Z is using
and what they mean,
and I promise it's not that serious.
this means that you're feeling kinda shy,
kind of like what this emoji,
at least in some scenarios, portrays.
for example I think you're really cute.
this means that you're listening and taking notes,
or that you want to or are going to take the advice.
the emoji can be used on its own,
but it's often used multiple times in one sentence
between each word.
for example
get a dog.
this means fishing for compliments or validation.
for example,
when someone posts something
where they're obviously trying to look good,
but the caption is self deprecating.
this one's easy.
it just is increase or decrease.
for example, my friend shared her study notes with me
and my respect for her went.
putting the sparkle emoji around one or more words
puts emphasis on it,
often ironically or sarcastically.
for example, I got a d on my test! fantastic!